*Sigh*
Today there would be a Corridor video
With a behind the scenes
To go with it
There is not
Let me wipe off all this pizza grease, off of my face
So I can talk to the internet
A delayed game that's good
Is still good forever
But if you rush a game and it's bad
Then it is bad forever
We had a lot of issues,
I pulled an all nighter, on Saturday
Trying to get this video done
And it's not done
Carmichael was working all day today
Trying to get the get the 'BTS' and the sound design done
For a number of reasons the video ended up having to be delayed
Till probably Wednesday
Wait if, the 'BTS' goes up on Wednesday, then when is the 'Nerf Infection' going up
I don't know when the next Sam and Niko video is about to go up
But don't worry
We know that you guys understand, but at the same time
We struggle to get you guys new content every other day
And new Corridor videos every other week
But...
Sometimes, when you are doing a concept that no one else has ever done before you run into issues
That are unforeseen
It is currently 10 P.M. on Sunday night, the day before the video is supposed to go up
Because this video got delayed
Carmichael is like "Man, a video has to go up."
He has never missed a video
Since the Vlog started
120 Vlogs ago?
If you truly enjoy this channel
And enjoy the content on this channel
You'll accept this
Needless to say- Woah that's zoomed
Hello, so yea needless to say there is awesome content coming soon
Normally there is one going up today
You're probably going to say "Hey you're making way more of a deal then it actually should be."
Hopefully you're correct
I'm going home
Oh, my leg